if thank you very much for the
introduction so we can view this talk as
unconditional lower bounds on the
running times of specific algorithms and
of classes of algorithms so first I will
we look at one problem max to CSP and
one specific algorithm for it and I will
try to convince you that the existing
analysis on the upper bound of its
running time is tight and I believe that
this lower bound even generalizes to
broader classes of algorithms for this
problem then I will talk about
innovation problems so a bunch of
algorithms are based on the enumeration
of some subsets and if the number of
such subsets is at least some function
of end and of course your warning time
will be lower bounded by this as well
let's let's start refer max to CSP so
the input is a graph G and a bunch of
score functions now the output will be
an assignment which is an assignment of
zero of values 0 1 2 vertices of the
graph with maximum score now what are
the scores so we have a neurotic score
which is basically just a constant that
is there for bookkeeping but you might
as well ignore it so very important and
you have a score for each vertex and for
each edge so a vertex gets a score
depending on the assignment you give it
so if you assign the value zero or two
vertex you get some score which is an
integer if you assign the value one to
the vertex you get a different score
which is an integer sir
we also have scores on edges and the
score and edge depends on the assignment
to its end points but as for possible
scores for an edge and two possible
scores for over text now we just want to
find an assignment to the vertices that
maximizes the sum of all the scores you
obtained here for example this problem
generalizes maximum independent set max
cut max to set and some other problems
and instead of having integer here you
could have formal variables and in that
case you get counter you get polynomial
tsps so your scores will then be formal
polynomials and you can do things like
counting objects of size K will stick
wave for max to CSV and that you could
also have a big domain in which case you
get max D CSP for the main st everything
I say still holds for polynomial csps
with domain size D but we will look at
max to CSP only so what is known about
this problem people have designed
algorithms for for this problem and
these are the current best upper bounds
so if you are allowed to use exponential
space that's why in Williams this
algorithm which ones in time to power
matrix multiplication / C times n and it
uses exponential space people have also
looked at getting better one in times
for sparse instances now imagine running
time in terms of the number of edges in
a graph and here the best known
algorithm has this running time which
basically just computes a tree
decomposition and uses a bounded rivets
based algorithm to compute the solution
so those dragons use exponential
expansion space now people are also
interested in polynomial space
algorithms measured in terms of the
number of vertices nothing better than
brute force is known and measured in
terms of number of edges there was a 2
power point 19m time algorithm by Scott
and soaking in 2007 and tree we look at
this algorithm in detail it has recently
improved to to powerpoint 18
so what I do now is I represent the
album by Scott at saucon and design a
lower bound for it as well that mattress
this upper bound and this is quite rare
actually so often in exponential time
algorithms we design algorithm we give
an upper bound on its running time but
very often when you ask people to give
you actually an instance that uses where
the album uses this time they can't come
up with one and usually you have upper
bounds and lower bounds that do not
match at all okay so let's get to the
algorithm by scott at saucon the first
thing it does is it applies some
simplification woods so reduction goals
four vertices of degree 0 1 and 2 so if
you have a vertex of degree 0 in your
graph well you get some score for
setting it to one you get some scuffles
setting it to 0 of course you want to
set it to the value that gives you the
maximum score well that's very very easy
you just study to evaluate case with
maximum score and then you deleted from
the graph you update the latex core
function with this maximum
if you have a vertex of degree 1 so what
can you do well for every foot for every
value of its neighbor you can check what
score do i get for this vertex and for
the edge that maximizes basically there
are the values oh but for which what
values do i maximize the sum of the
vertex at some of this course of the
vertex and the edge so we do this for
every value of neighbor and this allows
us basically to integrate this vertex V
and its edge into this core function of
its neighbor so this is very easy and it
can also be done four vertices of degree
2 now for every assignments to the
neighbors of V we can check how do I
optimally need to set V so as to
maximize this some of the scores of this
edge V and that other edge and then i
can again integrate all of this into one
edge on the two neighbors of V now I can
remove V and it's incident address ok so
we can easily deal with vertices of
degree at most 2 now if we if every
vertex has degree at least three we just
do a very simple branching so we select
a vertex with maximum degree and this
are going to prefer to select one with
maximum degree that has an a bar that
has degree less than the maximum degree
now it is a simple bunching setting this
vertex 20 or 21 and then recursively
solving the two instances set your type
okay so did her going to miss very
simple but it is quite hard to to come
up with a better blanching holes in my
opinion um let's look at what happens
for the degree 3 case so suppose your
input graph has maximum degree 3 so by
using the simplification rules we've got
maximum degree 3 and minimum degree 3 so
your graph will be three were three
regular so what does the algorithm do
done well it selects a vertex and it
sets it to 0 or 1 and then what happens
so this vertex disappears the neighbors
become of diggy too so the degree to
reduction applies to them so there we
move and an edge is created in their
neighborhood instead if it wasn't
present already so in the worst case how
many edges get deleted so we analyze the
running time in terms of number of
address now so here we see that nine
address get deleted and three new
address can potentially appear so then
that effect is the removal of six
address in each of the two branches
and then since we remove six address in
each of the two branches we get the
running time of 2 power m / 6 where
ambition is number of edges for cubic
instances and then the analysis of Scott
and second is a linear programming
analysis so it's basically equivalent to
measure and conquer where you assign the
potential function to your instances and
track the progress you make in terms of
that potential function so for measuring
conquer we usually optimize the weights
of this potential function with a convex
program but since in this problem
basically the two instances we create
are equal or they have equal weight at
least so they have equal measure for
this potential function this convex
program we'd use us to a linear program
actually and so they did an LP analysis
of this algorithm and deduce that if you
can solve the cubic case in this time
then you can solve general max to CSP in
that time for for this function better
of alpha and by applying this they did
you take included next to CSP can be
solved in time to power point 19 so when
I first saw this algorithm I was quite
happy to read it but I was quite
disappointed at the end because I had no
idea how to improve it and it's just
simply possibility had done everything
you should do and yeah I just gave up so
moving the analysis indeed seems very
difficult so the type constraints in the
analysis is where you have one type
constraint for degree fee we're
basically the six address disappear and
nothing else happens for bonchon degree
for the type constraints is one neighbor
self degrees four four four and three
four boundary one degree 5 the worst
cases when the neighbors have to be 5 55
five and four so you might wonder so why
is it not the 55 s but the case where
you have a you need to select a vertex
of degree 5 we're all neighbors of
degree 5 cannot occur too often so
actually it can occur only once unless
you disconnect your back unless your
graph as multiple connected components
so these are the worst case branchings
in this analysis of Scotland saucon and
what we do is we actually construct
instances where the algorithm only want
is according to these three branchings
but it only well it always i dub
launches on a vertex of degree 3 where
nothing else happens already give for
vertex with neighbours electives on
degree 5 and neighbor selectors and no
additional simplifications happen
moreover we need to select despawn
drinks in the white proportion to get
actually this lower bound on the running
time so in the most general case we have
a five regular graph where the eigen has
two branch and by eight times on degree
three vertices 3 and divide by 20 times
on degree 4 vertices and n by five times
and divide by five times on degree 5
vertices interestingly this proportion
of the branching cases comes out of the
LP analysis actually you can compute it
from the duel of the LP and this somehow
leads me to believe that maybe for many
other measure and conk analysis the
current analysis might be tight except
that we didn't manage to design such
instances where this running time occurs
ok so for degree 3 graphs this is quite
easy so I have a three by drag graph I
want that well what should happen to my
instance well exactly this so six
objects should disappear and I should
create three new edges and this scheme
should be applied over and over again
instant case for this graph so we just
have this these um these sub graphs
arranged in a cycle now if you choose
this wet vertex here and punch on it
what happens where the vertex disappears
we create a bunch of degree 2 vertices
they get simplified and you place all of
this by an edge and again we have a
quite similar graph accepted its four
vertices shorter and here again the
algorithm might select again one of
these vertices since the argument
doesn't specify which vertex to select
we can make it selected dispatcher at X
note that if we give it selected this
vertex that would be much better for the
argument because the whole instance
would disappear
okay so but on this graph now depending
on the decisions Garrigan the algorithm
makes the running time is 3 to the 2 to
the n divided by 4 which is for pubic
waves 2 power M divided by 6 now for you
give for graphs what do we do well we
start from this construction for the you
three graphs select a perfect matching
in that graph deleted we delete the
edges of this perfect muttering and
basically we place them by this
construction
now okay on this graph discovers maximum
degree fall so the algorithm is selected
you give for vertex preferably with a
neighbor of degree less than four for
example this red vertex here so now it
bounces on this retro tax what happens
is that this vertex disappears all its
incident address disappear now the this
path on degree two vertices appears or
this vertex will get to be too so it
gets reduced away and it basically
equates this edge that we delete it
before next vertex to bonchon couldn't
be this vertex etc so it branches on
every second vertex in the top well and
after doing this it leaves us with just
know about construction for the g3 grass
I'm what do you five we're going to rely
on the previous two graphs for the g3
and Diggy fall but now the proportion
must be somehow different so note that
if for the gift for the degree for
construction we really exhausted but we
really added a maximum number of degree
4 vertices but here we shouldn't add as
many to give 5 vertices as you can
because in the end we need to be left
with some graph where the album will
branch on degree force first and then we
need more DV three vertices to bundle
what happens here is the alga me respond
on these middle vertices and then what's
left is this lower bound for the g4 and
this lower bound for the GV that are
somehow connected in an appropriate way
so what you get in the end is lower
bound by graphs or instances where da
grandmas cotton Sorkin will really use
this much time the shows them that their
analysis was tired for you give three
four and general instances
so more generally say that an algorithm
is myopic if basically what it can do is
go through all the vertices look at the
neighborhoods of this vertex of each
vertex and decide on which vertex to
branch on choosing the best such vertex
by characterizing the vertex just by a
fixed ball radius around it so which
means that we can only check local
properties but no global properties so
could for example those four vertices
and always remember the best one you
encountered so far are always just
checking a local ball around a droid x
so our conjecture is that actually this
cubic lower bound also holds for myopic
blanching algorithms for cubic max to
CSP that is based on the same reduction
and simplification rules so now what you
can change as you select this vertex
differently on which your branch so I
believe that this doesn't have
and I also believe that this doesn't
have in general so for fortran room next
to csv and moreover i believe that this
is true for every myopic branching
algorithm note that the contract
conjectures become stronger and stronger
so now knob discussion is ok now if we
don't restrict ourselves to myopic
branching algorithms can we do better by
exploiting global properties yes you can
so in polynomial space we can exploit
separate tasks that are balanced and
allow us to basically branch on the
vertices in the support and an exploit
the fact that in the end we get
disconnected components where we get a
huge gain because we can solve them
independently there's a recent algorithm
where we apply this idea and we managed
to get the measure and conquer analysis
wide and adapt it to this kind of
supporters so we get in general for
Daniel grass you get an improvement
phone from point 19 m to point 18 m the
biggest improvement is for cubic
instances where we improve it from m /
62 m / 7.5
okay so we already started to talk a bit
about classes of algorithms using these
myopic blanching algorithms but now I
want to talk about enumeration
algorithms and specifically about
algorithms that enumerate objects let me
start with maximal independent sets this
is a well-studied class of objects so it
is known for a long time already that
the maximum number of maximal
independent sets in any graph of n
vertices is up and lower bounded by 3 to
the power and divide by 3 the bounds
that are given in literature a much more
precise but what I really care about is
the exponential factor or lower bound
examples are these graphs so if you have
a disjoint union of triangles every
maximal independent set contains one
vertex from each triangle and since they
are n divided by three triangles and you
have three choices for each triangle we
have this bound and then four depending
on number vertices you get slightly
different bonds so the enumeration of
maximal independent sets is used for
example for three coloring so this is
los three coloring algorithm so we can
assume that without loss of generality
one color class is a maximal independent
set otherwise take a colouring recolor
some vertices wedge so as to make your
red color Plaza maximal independently so
now the algorithm can just go through
through all maximal independent sets of
the graph and check whether if you
remove it you get a bipartite graph if
so return yo return yes otherwise return
0
so the running time is of this algorithm
is 32 power and thirds and of course you
cannot do better really for this
specific algorithm you cannot do that
better because of this lower bound
example which is of course trivially
three colorable but this is a lower
bound for the running time of the
algorithm as well so we can and this
idea for maximal intensity has been used
for many different problems and so
there's a bunch of algorithms that rely
on the enumeration of all maximal
independent sets of a graph and of
course the running time that the running
time is lower bounded by the enumeration
of all these Maximilian pencils there's
a bunch of other objects that we could
look at besides maximal independent sets
for example we could look at maximal by
klicks minimum feedback vertex sets the
aisle focus on minimal separators and on
minimal hitting sets
so the green rows here are tight so we
have a matching lower bound to the upper
bound but for many other objects we
don't have matching lower ones and upper
bounds for minimal separators the bound
previously was through to the end thirds
but it has been improved very slightly
let's look at minimal hitting SATs first
so it isn't this an easy one so we
basically take the maximal independent
set lower bound and generalize it to
hypergraphs of larger rank so we
basically take 2k minus 1 vertices build
all hyper address or possible hyper
address of size K now if we select k
vertices we hit all the sets we hit all
the hype edges but any few our vertices
miss at least one hi bache so in this
way we generalize these triangles to
basically complete hypergraphs of larger
rank and get this lower bound ok this is
very easy one let's look at minimal
subway toes
so what's a minimal separator well first
of all if I mpr two vertices in a graph
then an a/b separator is a set of
vertices such that it's no pass from A
to B when you move these vertices when
you move to set an a B separate as
minimal if it's not properly contained
in and any other a B separator and a
vertex set is a minimal separator if it
is a minimal separator a minimal a B
separator for some pervert aces a be so
this might be a slightly unusual
definition of minimality and it makes
that this set s1 is a minimal separator
where the superset s2 is also a minimal
separator namely s2 is a minimal a
separator where s 1 is not an AE seven
okay so what was known already is that
the nub maximum number of minimal a be
supporters in armenia phone and vertices
is at least 3 to the n thirds and this
can be seen by the following graph well
to separate a from B you need to select
one vertex from each of these rows so
that V choices in each row this gives
you three to the answers and this was
sort for a long time to be possibly also
the maximum you could get to convince
you that this is not a tight lower bound
I'll improve it first very slightly by
an easy construction so now suppose we
have 126 such vows so 126 is 92 is for
here we have nine vertices each of these
vertices is connected to exactly four of
these nine vertices such that no two of
these vertices are connected to exactly
the same months that's where you have n
choose four works in
now look at all the separators that do
not contain any vertex from the first
world then where they must contain the
four vertices that this vertex is
adjacent to in this column okay so for
the remaining rows I they still have
some neighbor in here all of them and we
have few choices for each other so the
remaining works that's 125 the three
choices for 125 wells and that was
excluding every vertex hundred first
level now the first of all is not
special so we could select any well to
exclude all the vertices from that world
as 126 wells and this is the number of
vertices in this graph which has
constant size but now we make copies of
this graph and merge the copies of a and
of B now it's easy to see that 126 is
more than 81 and that's why it is lower
bound is larger than the previous one we
can push this further to a larger bound
and the current best upper bound is this
we just simplify to prove little bit and
we conclude so in running time of
discordance walking algorithm for next
to a CSP is tight and just leads me to
believe that many other measure and
conquer analysis might be tight as well
so for the number of extremely vertex
sets in graphs there's been a renewed
interest over the last six seven years
motivated by exponential time algorithms
and you could discuss of course how much
space these use and what the delay
what's the delay of the corresponding
enumeration algorithm